لم نتمكن من الوصول اليه هكذا كان رد
القضاء اللبناني لنظيره الفرنسي الذي
استدعى رياض سلامه فاين اختفى حاكم مصرف
لبنان الذي لم نتمكن نحن ايضا كصيحفيين من
الوصول اليه خلال مهماتنا صحفيه
هنا داخل الرقط المصري في المركزي يعيش
الحاكم هكذا يقول اللبنانيون فالمؤتمن على
مدخراتهم غادر منزله منذ ان بدا بعض
القضاه بملاحقته رفض القضاء الفرنسي
الاعذار الواهيه التي اعتاد القضاء
اللبناني على اعطائها فصدرت مذكره توقيف
دوليه لا يعلم حتى الان ما اذا كانت
القاضيه ادرزي قد ارفقتها بطلب الشاره
الحمراء من الانتربول لكن مذكره التوقيف
ما كانت لتصدر لولا وجود شبهه دامغه
رح يدعي اسباب
الاسباب منا شد بس راح يستعمل معاهده اونو
رح يقول لهم لانه حضر الارضيه قبل وقت
الدعوه بنفس الاسباب يلي دع عليه القضاء
الاوروبي تيقول هو انه انا عندي اجراءات
وادعى قبل ما ينتهي القضاء الاوروبي يعني
من شان هيك راح يقول انا عندي اجراء قائم
على نفس الاسباب القانونيه اللي انتم
متدين عليها وفقا للمعاهد الامم المتحده
انا الي حق تابع المسار وانتم بتعلقوا
مساركوا لحديت متابع المليحه بعد مذكره
التوقيف على اصوات مطالبه بعزل حاكم
المصرف حفاظا على ما تبقى من سمعه للبنان
الا ان حقوقيين يؤكدون انه كان من المفترض
على سلامه تعليق مهامه منذ اللحظه الاولى
لصدور الاتهامات هو جزء من منظومه متكامله
وهذه المنظومه هيدي المنظومه لازم تعزل
خلت لبنان يصير مقفلس اقليميا ودوليا
ماليا ونقديا واقتصاديا
والعشرين من الشهر الحالي تعلن بريزيه
قرارها اما بتثبيت الحجز او رفعه عن املاك
سلمه املاكن لم تحركوا الدوله ساكنا باخذ
صفه الادعاء الشخصي للمحافظه عليها مما
يعني خسائر اضافيه لللبنانيين غنوه يتيم
العربيه بيروت لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات